[Aplausos]
aplausos unánimes y un texto presentado
con orgullo al público
tras varios meses de negociaciones los
dirigentes militares y civiles han
llegado a un acuerdo para poner fin a la
crisis el primero de los dos pasos del
proceso político para devolver el poder
a los civiles
insistimos en que la sociedad civil debe
ser independiente neutral y profesional
no debe estar vinculado al partido
gobernante debemos construir un estado
patriótico en lugar de un estado al
servicio de un partido
en la sala está el general artefata
alburhane El hombre fuerte del país con
el puño en alto el 25 de octubre de 2021
fue el quien tomó el poder mediante un
golpe de estado a continuación destituyó
a los representantes del pueblo poniendo
de hecho en pausa la transición iniciada
en 2019 tras la caída de Omar al bachill
en el poder durante 30 años a este golpe
de estado se suma a una crisis económica
cada vez más grave agotada la población
se revela casi a diario las calles se
convirtieron en escenario de
manifestaciones a gran escala contra los
militares en una declaración conjunta
varios países entre ellos Estados Unidos
acogieron con satisfacción la firma de
este acuerdo hablando de un primer paso
esencial la segunda fase debería
comenzar en unas semanas justicia
reformas del ejército varios puntos
cruciales pero todavía no se han
abordado ninguno de ellos